et
avant de commencer notre feuilleton une
mise au point s'impose
beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs
s'étaient plaints et j'adore chris coons
était petit motif view je n'avais pas de
sens et par conséquent ça ne présentait
aucun intérêt que vous et éducatif sauf
éventuellement pour les chats les chiens
et les demeurés moto at-on nous de dire
que c'était les spectateurs là avait
entièrement raison et ont fait preuve
d'une très grande perspicacité et
intelligence
un château plus de prêts en effet
quelque chose de complètement idiot
voyez plutôt non plus bien quand ça en a
un c'est jamais le bon quant aux points
lux culture et éducation
n'en parlons pas il serait donc injuste
d'imposer à ses téléspectateurs le
scandaleux spectacles d'animaux ou
hybrides
pourquoi si nous avons cédé malgré tout
devant l'insistance des shadoks
reparaître à partir d'aujourd'hui sur
vos écrans c'est à la condition formelle
et express qu'il ferait un effort réel
et sincère pour développer leur
intelligence et relever ainsi le niveau
éducatif et culturel de leurs émissions
les shadoks l'ont promis dans le cadre
de la campagne d'éducation des shadoks
que nous avions convenu au début de
notre feuilleton bâloise est ce que vous
prenez pour de logique shadok professeur
jadot qu au programme les passoires
on n'avait pas tout instrument sur
lequel veut définir trois sous-ensembles
l'intérieur l'extérieur et les coûts
l'intérieur est généralement placés au
dessus de l'extérieur et se compose le
plus souvent de nouilles et dont les
trous ne sont pas importants en effet
une expérience sein permet de se rendre
compte que l'on ne change pas
notablement les qualités de l'instrument
en réduisant de moitié le nombre des
trous puis qu'on réduise en cette moitié
de moitié et caetera et caetera et à la
limite jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
trous de tous tout théorème la notion de
passoire est indépendante de la notion
de trous et réciproquement
on n'appelle pas soir du premier ordre
les passoires qui ne laisse passer ni
les nouilles ni l'eau on n'appelle pas
soir du second tour dans les passoires
qui laisse passer et les nouilles et
nous on appelle pas soir du troisième
ordre ou passoire complexe les passoires
qui laisse passer quelques fois le new
look et quelquefois pas pour qu'une
passoire complexe laisse passer l'eau et
pas les nouilles
ils font t il suffit que le diamètre des
trous soit notablement inférieur au
diamètre des nouilles pour qu'une
passemar complexe laisse passer les
nouilles et palau il faut et il suffit
que le diamètre des trous soit
notablement inférieur au diamètre de
l'eau quant aux parts soir du premier
rang qui nous laisse passer ni les nous
unit lot il y en a 2 200 les passoires
qui ne laisse passer ni les nous
nello ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre et
16 qui ne laisse passer ni les nouilles
ni l'eau que dans un sens seulement
c'est pas soir là on les appelle des
casseroles le calcul leur avaient
toujours donné pas mal de fil à retordre
étant donné qu'ils avaient été 4 mou et
qu'il ne pouvait pas compter plus loin
que 4 vous souvenez mais le professeur
chat de cours avait réformé tout ça
écoutons jean ce quand il n'ya pas de
shadow qu'on dit gars et on décrit quand
il ya un shadok de plus au début et on
écrit quand il ya encore un chat d'oc
ont disons et on écrit et quand il ya
encore un autre on dit me et en écrit
tout le monde a pondu cet accord est
trouvé ça génial
un verre de vin plus utilisé contre le
poly d'un soutien des enfants des
bêtises pareilles et que ce cadre qu il
fallait le condamner il fut très
applaudi les mathématiques l'intéressé
bien sûr les brûler le professeur
c'était intéressant aussi pour dire vous
décider à lunettes beauté qu'on le
laisse parler des coûts brûlerait après
à la récréation réputé avec moi me sont
bulgares qu'un but on ne trie après des
années de plomb dit si je mets un shadok
en plus évidemment je n'ai plus assez de
mots pour les courtes et alors c'est
très simple on les jette dans une
poubelle et je dis que j'ai bu poubelles
et pour ne pas confondre avec le bus du
début je dis qu'il n'ya pas de chat d'oc
à côté de la poubelle et j'écris du cas
on continue oiseaux poubelles et pas de
chat d'oc à côté mais si je mets un
shadok en plus il me faut une autre
poubelle
mais comme je n'ai plus de mots pour
compter des poubelles je m'en débarrasse
en des jetons dans une grande poubelle
j'écris plus grande poubelle avec pas de
petites poubelles n'est pas du chat d'oc
à côté bulgare gars et on continue quand
on arrive là et qu'on a trop de grandes
poubelles pour pouvoir des comtés et
bien roulé mais dans une super poubelle
on écrit bugat gaga et on continue pour
pondre neuf chez des shadoks légalement
fallait savoir compter jusqu'à 4 1 mois
mais il y en avait qui trichent et qui
s'y mettaient à deux un mois les gens
ignorants et salace sim était tout
bonnement à 4 bat très et ça faisait
donne scandaleux c'est que ces imbéciles
a trouvé ces genres de pratiques
excessives en t'amusant salehi m le hall
l'ordinateur suis d'avis que pour pondre
un oeuf il fallait savoir compter au
moins jusqu'à 10 le contrôleur des
hautes études circulatoire écologique
dès qu'il fallait un permis de ne pas
compter ça l'arrangé vu qu'il ne savait
raconter entre 0 et 10 naturellement au
transige à assen le sort qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui cherté des spectateurs que
j'adopte pour contre 9 faudra savoir
compter jusqu'à sept
tout cela remet en cause les fondements
mêmes de la mathématique shadow qui
prouve une fois de plus que la
sexologique est affaire de mathématiques
mais on ne peut pas parler de
mathématiques devant les enfants
[Musique]
obama
le poids des finitions le point est la
plus courte distance possible entre deux
lignes première application étant
données de l'ign quelconque trouver
l'endroit où elle se coupe
supposons qu'elle se rencontrant zoé me
par exemple s'il en est ainsi d'après
notre définition la ligne zoho me serais
un point et serait plus courte que le
point but or ce n'est pas le cas donc
les lignes se rencontrent en bus d'où
théorème deux lignes qui se rencontrent
se rencontrent toujours au même endroit
propriétés remarquables tout ligne
prises hors d'un point ne passe pas par
ce point ou alors si ali passe c'est
vraiment par hasard
deuxièmement les points parallèle on dit
qu'un point est parallèle à deux autres
points lorsque ce point est en cours n'a
blement disposer si on le déplace d'un
côté ou de l'autre
il est plus parallèle
d'où théorème la condition suffisante
pourquoi points restent bien parallèles
à deux autres points et qu'il reste là
où il est et qu'il ne bouge pas deuxième
partie d'année on appelle ligne de
premier choix lénine qui ne passe que
par des points parallèle on appelle
ligne chad o'quinn encombrante les
lignes qui passe plusieurs fois par un
même point ou par plusieurs on appelle
ligne de deuxième catégorie des lignes
qui arrive sur un point qui s'arrête on
appelle ligne deux dernières catégories
ou petites lignes les lignes qui ne
passe que par un seul point
[Musique]
et maintenant un petit exercice de
mathématiques shadow si un chat 2 que
pour moi le long d'une ligne de premier
choix parcours shadoks mettre à l'heure
combien mettra-t-il de temps pour
parcourir tour du chapeau mais tout ce
qui n'est pas explicitement autorisée
est strictement interdite quand je ne
veux pas exemple et est en train de
tourner à gauche
il fallait qu'il continue à tourner à
gauche
jusqu'à ce qu'ils peuvent a non pour
tourner à droite
s'il allait tout droit fallait qu'il
continue sur les routes à grande
circulation par exemple il y avait
seulement un bout un panneau qui disait
d'avancé et à l'autre bout un panneau
pour recul pour le reste les shadows
call est à l'ordinateur passer leur
permis à ceux reconnus les plus aptes on
donnait un permis de ne pas conduit le
chef de quart et les autres sur le bord
de la route et demandait au fresnoy
votre permis mais je ne les fais du vélo
à ses très bien alors roulé l'ordinateur
chats blogs dans son principe reposer
sur deux bases logiques
la première lui servait à se reposer la
deuxième était hypothétique et lui
servait à faire des calculs
ces calculs et est effectué selon la
méthode dite du calcul des probabilités
quand on lui demande est une addition de
plus 2 par exemple il répondait c'est
probable que ça fasse quelque chose
[Musique]
il y a une chance sur deux que ça fasse
33 et le chant / but que ça fasse
n'importe quoi d'autre de zéro à
l'infini compte si on lui a demandé de
calculer nos chaussures but il répondait
selon le même principe que le sang pur
but on avait une chance sur deux que ça
fasse une sauce je prend 2,3 et une
chaussure but que ça fasse n'importe
quoi on appelait ça le principe
d'incertitude
parce qu'il y avait une chose dont on
est sûr c'est que c'était faux ou alors
si c'était juste c'était vraiment par
hasard ou qu'il y avait une erreur
quelque part il fournissait aussi de la
logique informelle dix ans tous les
chats sont mortelles socrates est mortel
donc socrate est un chat ça ne faisait
pas tellement shadoks socrates soit dit
en passant mais ça sortait de
l'ordinateur et c'étaient là des rides
[Musique]